comment allez vous messieurs dames je
suis avec locklear monsieur pas la paume
de la main et fait piquer par une méduse
tu veux en parler aux gens oui alors
cette méduse m'a piqué depuis quelques
semaines maintenant je peux vous dire
c'est incroyable le saviez vous laisse
toi qui me l'a appris
uriner dessus ça sert à rien ça sert à
rien ne fait pas ça s'est empiré les
choses on sait qu'ils connaissent pas
locklear grand streamer crime très
souvent avec lui chez une patiente
roukaya le live est un type hd simplifie
toujours sa pub vous avez elle est
habituée avec l'oc ça fait un moment
qu'on veut venir en aide à un streamer
qui est le new day habitants c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui médias passionné qui
a à peine le mât tout ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir streamé et qui galèrent un pas
parce que dès que tu te lances là dedans
c'est un milieu très concurrentiel très
dur c'est très dur d'émerger encore plus
aujourd'hui
et donc il ya des tas de gens sur
internet soit youtube ou twitter qui
font des stream et qui ont 3 4 viewers
mais qui stream de manière assidue quand
même et qui sont mes gars passionné
on a donc cherché plein de petites
pépites de petits streamer avec l'ocs et
y en a des tonnes malheureusement on
peut venir en aide car l'un d'eux parce
qu'on ne peut pas aider 3000 personnes à
coup c'est pas possible on s'est donc
dit mec vient on en trouve un on essaie
de rentrer en contact avec un proche à
lui et on lui fait la surprise de venir
chez lui à l'improviste pour refaire
tout son set up refaire tout son décor
refaire sa direction artistique c'est à
cette ces visuels et le conseiller quoi
qui passe de streamer amateurs à
streamer professionnels on va le piper
quoi la prod a réussi à rentrer en
contact avec la meilleure amie de l'un
de ses nombreux streams qui s'appelle i
siam le streamer en question s'appelle
comme référence aux notes afférentes au
score on lui a donc posé la question
suivante salue ici yann pourquoi on
devrait venir aider fr underscore zhob
et elle nous a fait cette vidéo fallu
squeeze salué l'acquis hier j'espère que
vous allez bien
si je vous contacte aujourd'hui c'est
pour vous parler de mon meilleur ami
maxime et s'est lancé sur twitter au
premier continent parce que son plus
grand rêve c'est de devenir streamer
professionnel à mon échelle je peux pas
réaliser son rêve je sais que vous fait
des miracles donc est ce que vous pouvez
me donner un tout petit coup de main
j'espère que vous auriez ma vidéo et
j'espère bientôt sa bulle
franchement elle le vend très bien elle
le vend trop bien mais on n'a toujours
pas vu le maximum
vive le trotski légal on a vu que c'est
vod que ça stream finances est sain et
donc on a envoyé la prod le film est
chez lui en se faisant passer pour la
prod d'une émission télé qui fait des
petits portraits / et des gros streamer
et des moyens streamer et des petits
stream axe formidable c'est formidable
20 vis bien faire on a donc une vidéo de
maxime qui parle un peu de pluie
sa passion pour quoi il arrive sa vie
privée tout ça et on va la regarder en
sommes aujourd'hui au nom ils ont mis la
musique vous aimez la musique triste
nouvelle maxime j'ai 26 ans et je suis
passionné de jeux vidéo alors dans la
vie bah je suis streamer cimr débutant
je suis un bébé encore pour l'instant
j'ai commencé il ya quelques mois et b
j'ai un parcours assez particulier parce
qu'à la base c'était pas du tout ce que
je voulais faire je devais avoir un
cursus classique normalement c'est à
dire faire mon master en communication
et ensuite avoir un job dans la com j'ai
perdu mon emploi il ya deux ans me suis
dit que j'allais faire un job
alimentaire en attendant malheureusement
j'ai eu un grave accident qui m'a fait
remettre beaucoup de choses en question
à savoir ce que je voulais vraiment
faire dans la vie en fait twitch c'est
un monde que j'affectionne énormément à
la base j'étais qu'un simple viewer et
lors du z event organisé par zerator
c'est un live caritatif en fait on se
souvient des terres gdt dans le chat tu
dois m'identifier à une personne se
serait locklear parce que ce qu'ils
véhiculent c'est exceptionnel a toujours
au taquet toujours rigoler tous sûrs
l'ipsi sanaa
[Musique]
ça c'est le pote de qui comment c'est
possible
non mais c'est pas possible mais qui bat
en fait c'est plutôt logique groupe d
streamer qui vivent de ça qui sont
connus qui font des milliers de joueurs
il y en a pas tant que ça moi je te le
dis tout de suite tu peux mettre pause
la vidéo on y va après ce qu'il vient de
dire et on y va rapidement
il ya doivent big j'aime énormément
aussi les orateurs qui est pour moi le
moi thatagat
son parcours la spouze y bien entendu
qui est à même le site et parce que
c'est logique on y va encore pouvoir
mélanger sa passion savoir le gaming à
une oeuvre caritative pour moi ça a été
un déclic
j'aurai réussi sur twitch quand j'aurais
participé aux est divin salut sur le
stream à j'ai commencé à investir dans
mon matériel vers mai juin et j'y suis
très sérieusement c'est à dire quasiment
quotidiennement à partir de septembre
on va aller voir sur twitter trackers si
c'est vrai on surveille frérot fait pas
la cédule ya de plus en plus de de
streamer et pour pouvoir en fait se
démarquer pour moi c'est nécessaire de
se professionnaliser donc une lights est
bien entendu nécessaire pour avoir un
bon retour au niveau de la caméra
ici un double écran c'est le minimum
habituellement le plus intéressant c'est
d'en avoir trois pour avoir en fait un
écran avec uniquement le chat un écran
gaming et un écran avec le retour du
stream et l'a vu les vidéos c'est top
des gros streamer fasse voir il est
vachement renseigner les gros stream et
un stream avec 2 pc un pc pour le gaming
et le deuxième décès pour le streaming
uniquement johnny car pour l'instant et
c'est amplement suffisant
le micro pour pouvoir se démarquer il
faut avoir la meilleure qualité de son
la meilleure qualité de caméras et les
vachement équipe énorme atos écoute mec
s'ils n'étaient pas équipés ils
pourraient pas streamé on cherche
gstreamer ici un et il faut qu'il soit
quand même un minimum
oui c'est vrai il tape dit que
j'aimerais ça sinon on va les aider que
moi j'avais un peu à peu près cet
équipement l'appareil au moment
je commençais les vidéos à l'époque donc
c'est assez impressionnant visuellement
mais en vrai de vrai il n'a pas la balle
dernier cri et où tu as la chaise pour
moi c'est indispensable parce que quand
on passe dès 10 heures ou plus à stream
il faut obligatoirement avoir du
matériel confortable parce que sinon
pour le dos on le sent pas si tu peux
nous parler de problèmes de dos il y
attache est non on va pas parler de mon
problème de dolly à ma chaise moi parce
que j'ai 30 ans j'ai tout donné j'ai
rien différent non j'ai jamais un signe
mais quoi que ce soit on va tout savoir
30 en un jour mais moi c'est dans cinq
ans alors le mur pour l'instant il est
complètement nu et c'est un petit peu
dommage parce que c'est ce que les
viewer voit en premier c'est ce qui est
derrière moi finalement quand je stream
je compte net des jeux vidéo des mangas
et énormément de choses qui me
passionnent n'est pas un mur blanc effet
la corde raide et les blancs le mur et à
rire sur les murs m à doha
je commençais déjà à mettre des light
pour que ça un petit peu plus chaleureux
mais clairement ça manque d'un des camps
derrière il n'a pas fait encore son
décor c'est ça c'est vachement
intéressant pour nous et il est très fan
des lettres des lumières des néons ça se
voit je commence à stream vers 23h
jusqu'à 4 5 6 heures du matin c'est un
peu plus libre également de gros
streamer présent pour se créer une
communauté c'est plus intéressant de
stream l'année c'est parti
[Musique]
salut tout le monde bienvenue aux
initiales on n'est pas tout seul
aujourd'hui les gars vous voyez à des
gens derrière moi c'est la télé les gars
n'ont alors on s'est fait berner tu es
un grand joueur call of duty depuis des
années c'est mon premier jeu sur console
je faisais des des vidéos sur call of
duty y s'a disant inspiré par sky rose
hill et des vidéos il ya dix ans j'ai la
chance d'avoir une commune vachement
active
même si je fais du 15 22 heures maximum
on a l'impression d'être d'être une
centaine salut sofiane salut au livre
comment il va montrer au sommet mais ce
serait pas ce bon vieux 0 juste là
comment ils vont tout le monde ça fait
plaisir de voir les gars c'est quoi ça
mais là moi je premier dog est à jamais
connu tout ça sur tweets j'ai comme ça
sur youtube pas sur toi tu fais mais
surtout de chemins quand tu te lances et
qu'il ya déjà des gens qui part dans ton
chat pour la première fois c'est
intriguant c'est incroyable mec moi j'en
appelle 2011
c'est des gens qui sont là quasiment
tous les jours si gens que j'apprécie
ces mêmes puis des viewer ses limites
des potes en fait on se raconte nos
journées où on parle de nos problèmes et
en fait ce que je véhicule et c'est sur
ce stream sur ma chaîne des chez toi en
fête familiale
j'aime bien si j'ai cette possibilité
d'avoir 100 200 300 400 500 joueurs
j'aurais même j'ai envie de jouer
ce que j'aime c'est animé discuter
rigoler avec les gens c'est juste ça je
fais des bisous l'erreur mais je vous
dis à ce soir ciao tout le monde bisous
mais il est parfait j'ai pas envie de
lui refaire son 7ème j'ai envie de lui
faire un câlin avant tout avec la petite
musique un bravo la prod c'est quoi leur
objectif c'est de me levant tu sais que
tu chiale alors sitôt si tu es une
personne qui m'aide énormément sur
twitch ceis yonne c'est notre complet ça
c'est notre infiltré des moments très
difficiles que ce soit dans ma vie perso
ou sur twitter grâce à elle j'ai pu
continuer j'ai pu arriver là où suis-je
choisi les gars je vous laisse avec
énormément apprécié par la communauté
il a préfère plus que moi je pense et
banier et baggy aussi voilà le chat
maxime c'est pour moi insouciant énorme
c'est la personne que j'appelle dès que
j'ai un problème c'est quelqu'un de
jovial c'est quelqu'un de charismatique
et c'est aussi quelqu'un de très angles
et chantant ne ressemble beaucoup sur
twitch et je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il ya une communauté aussi
bienveillante
c'est particulier parce que twitch c'est
un milieu qui est très volatile
tu peux rester pendant des années à 10
15 20 viewer et d'un coup par un
événement x ou y exploser aujourd'hui
j'ai pas la chance de pouvoir en vivre
mais je débute c'est pas c'est pas du
tout un problème clairement c'est un
rêve qui est très difficile à atteindre
c'est bien de se fixer des objectifs
la voilà je vise un peu les étoiles mais
voilà peut-être un jour et comme on dit
mon vieux zod faut viser les étoiles
pour atteindre le ciel c'est une très
belle conclut séjour mais qu il est
parfait il est génial mais en fait il y
en a plein des hommes c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre
in stat qui est assez incroyable vous
vous rendez compte de à quel point ya
beaucoup d'hommes tués dans les 1% les
plus suivis de twitch quand tu as à
peine quelques dizaines guillaume tu te
rends compte c'est complètement vous
débarque chez au delà on va se résoudre
c'est ce que c'est le plan dix mois
issia elle nous a filé les clés de
l'appartement de zob aujourd'hui elle
est en balade avec lui pendant ce temps
là nous on va aller chez lui et quand il
rentrera en fera bon plan hockey et à
partir de là on prend les choses en main
on refait tout son bail
ok mais avant ça on va évidemment lui
demander de stream est un petit peu
langlois de quoi il est capable
là aujourd'hui bien sûr toi je sens
qu'il va être très dur avec lui leclerc
est impitoyable il va rien laisser
passer rien twitch et impitoyable
mesdames et c'est un monde impitoyable
c'est vrai je suis plus que prêt mec
[Musique]
on pénètre dans le van parys et à toute
heure
[Musique]
dans paris avec itium il est pas au
courant il arrive dans une faille à des
fenêtres et où j'ai trop peur que les
gens qui nous voyaient un tweet donc
venez on fonce dans son appart on a les
clés on y va on se pose il va on se fait
un petit et on se fait un café on june
on joue ce sera fait comme chez nous et
riner il arrive et c'est la surprise
n'est debout à l'est a tout de suite
alors je pense qu'il va faire très chaud
jusque là dehors il fait 31° à mon avis
être compliqué
[Musique]
sarah perreault allait rentrer dans ton
cul
c'est fermé serait mais quelqu'un
[Musique]
ce handicap tête une sorte de milice les
audiences les eaux direct et la
communauté job c'est les zodiac s'est
référé à 6 bientôt il va chercher ses
missions il ya des chats les inconnus si
les défonce et excuse moi tu pars en
randonnée ou chez au delà je comprends
pas tu viens quotidien s'est jamais
groupe collectionne des sneakers et toi
tu es tout tomber est sympa le petit
appartenant carré alors attendez parce
que moi les accros jeu vidéo là qu'ils
vivent dans des conditions cros manosque
ça me rend malade n'a jamais fait ça
tous les jours de mon adolescence mais
avec moi j'étais sur le toit paquette
m'ont vu que c'était tout le temps fermé
le set-up bon c'est excellent mais pour
être un streamer ça suffit pas c'est sûr
mais qu'on peut tous amélioré c'est sûr
c'est ça tu vois que je dois améliorer
la fin on n'a pas pensé sa télé on
aurait dû changer sa télé mais quel
rapport entre une télé est streamé bien
jouer c'est bon il ya la télé c'est
génial ça te garde sa télé pourquoi j'ai
envie de fouiner de malades c'est quoi
c'est quoi cette pulsions malsaines
est ce que je peut pointer les heineken
qui laisse au soleil à 31° tête il aime
la bière chaude c'est tout j'ai trouvé
une carte d'anniversaire on peut aller
au séjour aux mecs
l'aic non écoutés souplex basique joyeux
anniversaire la future star de twitch
nom alice elle a juste marqué joyeux
anniversaire un peu radine alice
holloway je suis chien stream amont un
coach sportif la route je sais pas j'ai
peut-être même les deux ça c'est quoi ça
sert à ça
ces mini zoo de sa féminisation du nez
frais ou le mec il est tout content que
tu t'imagines il arrive chez toi il
prend les photos
il a dans son salon c'est qu'elle est là
pour qu'on la voit non mais enfin pour
que ses invités la voit pas et moi je
suis un zodiac créerait je fais partie
de la coque d'un coup moi aussi je suis
un audience je vous jure à la fin de la
vidéo vous serez tous des audioguides
assieds toi fais comme chez toi alors
temps je fait allumer mon ordi up
merci on fait allez vas-y instat war et
pas de me passer son ordinateur maxime
je vois pas en quoi ces mannes qu'il ait
pas de mots page henri viii sol
cambrioleurs même hacker distance tout
il faut avoir un mot de passe
je peux acheter ton information volé ma
formation en ligne elle est sur twitter
pointer les sages l'obtenir mesdames et
messieurs qu'est ce qu'il a comme jeu où
non vpn ou verrait bien que nos vaches
targon porter comme acheter son ordi il
arrive on se cache on se cache il a une
salle de bain d'un mois lui il arrive
par là mais on est dans la salle de
bains et une fois qu'il est là et qui
voit l'équipe technique et qui fait ou
qu'est ce qu'il fait là un espace sauf
derrière lui on sent qu est bien bas
voici bien ouais il arrive donc
maintenant là il courait parce qu'ils
avaient envie de pisser attiva non mais
là on fait quoi on est mort attention il
va griller
quoi bon restons simples en vos chères
têtes enflées il va se poser dessus
et s'il commence à cette force et non
mais franchement c'est pas gégène 16h02
qu'il allait laisser pisser mais quitter
ton à frire on imagine turgis tout agent
ce qu'il fit tu te rends compte qu'ils
couraient il courait
[Musique]
non
les bons jours ça fait longtemps
tout le monde
comment salon feront pareil quand ça va
y va pisser mappy c'est papy c'est vrai
au secteur 8 puis c'est pas pu se
régaler
on ne va pas tenir longtemps voilà
directs dégagent et savent à quoi ils
servent
gg pour la surprise tuner salé s'est
désolé je l'envoie piscine culpabiliser
trop sinon on a entendu gema s'insurge
des faits on a fait trop dur amazon
arrive à plisser merde on a bloqué le
cbo table cet avis est en tout cas tu as
fait ton vif rebond mais mon appart et
tes parents j'ai nommé paga pas je
souhaite c'est pourquoi on est là zone
banon nous sommes là en tant que
professionnel du streaming des milliers
de joueurs
les milliers plein dopé nadeau de
passage oui de passion et aujourd'hui on
a la peau td dans ta carrière de
streamer il ya du boulot
il ya du boulot mais avant quand tu
aimes tu va évidemment nous présenter un
peu ton c'est toi père tu nous envoies
laquelle on alors je peux vous dire une
dalle juste avant comment ça c'est quand
j'ai un rendez-vous quand je vois
quelqu'un mon appart est toujours rangé
mais là je me suis dit je te crois pas
mais je te promets que c'est ridicule ce
qu'ils se fassent enfin bon bah voilà
mon petit set up cc pour commenter ces
légers soit c'est parce que je sais que
twitch aujourd'hui autant parler surtout
là c'était vraiment fou theron ferez
quoi et en parler sur ce ton là via
j'écoute attentivement à chaque fois
d'ailleurs je t'ai envoyé quelques dm
jamais répondu mais non tu disais qu
aujourd'hui tweet ça s'est
professionnalisé à mort est en fait si
tu veux réussir à faire quelque chose
faut commencer avec quelque chose de
cali en fait mais je vais aller faire
pipi
justement je reviens vous restez non non
non je cassais ballet en tout cas
c'était vraiment plaisir c'est fou ça
pas professionnel zone tu vas reconnu
les membres de l'équipe technique
c'était notre équipe qui était venue
avec la complicité évidemment du siam et
on a vu un petit portrait sur toi on a
vu ce genre ton set up où tu parle de
toi on en sait un peu sur toi mais bien
pourquoi tu te grattes tout le monde
coule on est venu pour t'aider comme
j'ai dit allons améliorer tout ça
améliorer tout ça
mais avant on aimerait voir le plus
important le plus important le test oui
on veut te voir en pleine action donc
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tu vas
t'asseoir et tu va lancer un live in on
va regarder ton live dans la pièce d'à
côté
comme ça on prend à l'improviste ma
petite remarque c'est que en tant que
petit streamer j'ai une plage horaire
bien définis à la base c'est à dire 18
23 et ses bars et j'ai peur de faire de
l'ombre un squeeze donc c'est pour ça
que je sois maire s'est fait un nom en
vrai nom richard c'est par respect pour
lui c'est pour ça aussi que par respect
que tu as pas lancer un stream depuis le
18 mai alors c'était et puisque c'est
terrible alors j'ai pu battre
quelle est la vraie raison d' il n ya
pas de problème moi c'est des fois je
fais pas de vidéo pendant deux semaines
jamais en disant jamais en dix ans
jamais je t'écoute
non la vraie raison c'est à l'été c'est
pas facile pour moi il fait beau il fait
chaud on n'a pas forcément envie de
rester non plus pour fermer à jouer je
partage la même chose d'ailleurs on a
trouvé un nom pour sa communauté
je t'écoute attention les zodiac
alors ouais c'est pas me les bières au
soleil alors tu vas là on va discuter
des trucs qui bougent pas c'est quoi ça
va très bien donc le mec qui fait le
gars que j'ai de la wii je prends soin d
électrolyse
les fouilles et bois des rhein et ken en
plein soleil c'est quoi c'est top 1
trouvez-moi des ventilos avec plus de
poussière mais revient l'aspi labatutois
les ventilos bordel à l'exode
ouais j'en ai plus qu'assez tu t'assois
turbulences en live à ses touches je te
bute
excusez-moi j'ai j'adore il va mettre
les mains sur les épaules oui alors
attendez j'adore ma non tu vas sinon je
te bute on te demande de tenir vingt
minutes à l'issue desquelles on aura
pris des notes
on te rejoins dans cette pièce et ont
fait un petit débrief à toi de jouer
fais nous rêver ça ok
bah allons-y ses partisans qui a fait
plaisir mais c'est parti c'est bon je
peux y aller ok bonjour à vous bienvenue
dans notre salut donc on a créé des
comptes réagit on va interagir dans son
chat ou un peu trop laid on va faire ce
qu'il faut hu a un peu ses réactions
salut tout le monde les gars ça me fait
plaisir de revenir ça l'excellent au
salut dany salut aux livres les gars
vous m'avez trop manqué une contre ça
fait un mois que j'ai pas streamé on va
y aller crescendo portland
merci pour ton pour ton follow merci à
tous moi je tenais à m'excuser l'épreuve
pour maintenance at il dit moi je suis
un journaliste qui est passé de sa peu
plaisir vraiment ça me fait plaisir pour
voir la ville quick qui parle pour tous
et tous qui active et que ces coups là
on a fini quatre joueurs et ça parle
c'est trop cool merci blablo pour tous
et merci à tous ça fait trop plaisir je
vous connecter alors sans faire beaucoup
et j'en vois des prout je visais frérot
est bon plus grand sommet en tous cas à
l'égard vraiment merci d'être resté
merci d'avoir pris des nouvelles de moi
faut pas que tu passes la avère qu on va
se lancer ce bon vieux cold war on va et
ce qu'on est toujours aussi bon sniper
ça fait plaisir mais je vais le dire
cinquante mille fois sur ce live c'est
bon mais y'a pas de problème
bon de donner moi des nouvelles de vous
dites moi comment vous verrez une revue
ouais je suis désolé les gars mon appart
est dans un état pitoyable
qu'est-ce que j'ai honte donc là on
des preuves l'imprévu en plein life
comment va t il réagir vous savez quoi
porto je suis passé jamment sûr avec ses
banques si on met un paix fréro je
m'appelle pour que les gars il a pas
d'âge pour ça a l'air d'être plus proche
des ménages 0,2 et xénophobe vraiment
j'ai pas string depuis c'était des
années tu vois des del au clair partout
toi c'était vrai je marque tout dans le
chat quand appui n'hésitez pas à me dire
niveau du son c'est comment si tout est
ok de votre côté vous envoie le prouve
oui ça ça fait plaisir c'était moi ça
les gars là des bruits bizarres sont
monstrueux
par contre les gars y'a badji cash à
regarder qui est là les gars est-ce
qu'on peut pas mettre autre chose
ce crime ce qui vous a pas eu
ok c'est bon c'est donc des sweats et
grâce à ses choix si c'est sensé choses
s'emballent et que je vais auquel tous
ces bruits il bouffe comme mon chat je
sais pas vous mais moi ok pas mal avec
son père maternel cheikh où puis je suis
autres choses bien bien bien ok
maintenant je passe un maxi troll tu
fais comme je vais sont générateurs 1re
as tu te fais ban a rappelé l'époque
j'étais très très chaud sur call of
j'étais le meilleur streamer français
sur cold war c'est absolument faux tu es
nul raconter de la merde avec une fausse
arme à auckland mais c'est qui ça c'est
qui ce troll les gars mais tu sais que
et pour ça je suis pas bien depuis
quelques semaines et c'est pour ça que
je serai plus trop j'ai des problèmes au
ventre les gars là on a dit voilà on va
tester ça n'arrive jamais si en fait mon
come back se résume à des bruits de pets
sur mon string
c'est effrayant je suis d'accord moi
j'écoute 30 secondes et gâche me suis
placé je veux que j'interviens évasif je
suis embrouillé que tu dis mais c'est
pas drôle c'est quoi ce streamer de
merde c'est durant ce qu'on en voit mais
on va voir comment il réagit à chablis
au modérateur à supprimer votre marché
déclare guy olive chill mon frérot livre
pas la peine de perdre ma ville est en
train de recadrer son moulin il lui dit
tranquille n'y a pas de souci mais c'est
pas drôle vous fait quoi sur ce stream
ce qu'ils vont me supprimer souhaitait
vraiment je suis en fait je sais les
messages que c'est rose et noir mat sois
gentil on est entre potes tout va bien
et les gars on insulte pas on est gentil
on est cordiale on est courtois au caire
pour des rigolos
pourquoi tu étais pas là pendant un mois
tu nous a abandonnés mais non je vous ai
pas abandonner l'erreur promis je vous
ai pas abandonner en fait vas-y la
vérité c'est ça un call of ça me faisait
plus tiphaine genre vraiment si j'en
avais marre de call of et savait pas
trop quoi stream
donc j'ai eu un temps de réflexion j'ai
trop projet les gars vraiment il a eu la
page de jeu en fait j'aurais il était
saoul et de ses jeux phares govou ce qui
est en train de dire qu'ils ne pensaient
qu'il est d'arriver par la passion et
qu' ils agitent le par passion
exactement et ce à quoi même sur quoi on
peut finir sur un centre là il faut que
je fasse une bonne grippe a repris ce
que tu peux mettre deux rives sur une
enceinte
salut à tous les gars pour ce kindle
[Musique]
vous entendez comme moi les gars y
croient trop c'est trop bien mais c'est
tout diagramme de travaux chez toi ou
moi je sais pas ce qui se passe chez moi
les gars une persona mais oui il ya un
mec qui tambourinent sur les contres en
face il ya des travaux les a vraiment à
deux doigts d'aller chez le voisin
vraiment des réactions un peu de recul
un peu fun en fait illégaux james bosh
est ce qu'on a le droit à une avant
première est bon les frérots je vais
kuyt là c'était un petit live furtif
il a fait une gamme low cost et je
voudrais encore une fois de m'excuser
les frérots de mon absence d'un mois
encore une fois merci à tous ceux qui
ont été là ont soutenu va on va revenir
fort là c'est dur la cdu risque château
mais quand tu trembles impossibile part
à l as tu lances jamais un accro à 30
minutes
désolé blue vraiment mais t'inquiète
vous n'allez pas être déçus va y avoir
du gros contenu et des prix vers 16
centres couronnées mais voilà j'avais
besoin de cette petite pause aussi ça
m'a fait le plus grand bien des bisous
les frérots et je vous dis du coup bas à
demain il y aura rien de nous et merci à
tous pour vos hommes merci micro bisous
tout le monde
ciao
[Musique]
bravo à lui c'était wah wah wah on a
fait tout ce qu'il faut mais pas sur la
mecque chanson je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez vous mais moi si tu étais moi
putman est vrai que c'était un squeeze
pour le coup à l'êta lance elle était
juste là et j'ai même pas tu l'as pas vu
vraiment ou non
moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien tu t'es pas
laissé surprendre par ce qui est arrivé
tout battez les coûts en plus dans une
position délicate où c'était ton combat
que ça faisait un mois que tu aime à
parler aux gens vous voyez de 3 gens de
la prod qui passa une petite commune qui
est bien forte et active quand même tu
as quand même lancé un live pas du tout
dans teaser de streaming illégaux il est
17h tu avais 12 20 personnes qui
arrivait et qui parlait d'un chat et
tout ça sont très engagés je trouve
c'est où ça n'a aucun sens ce street n'a
aucun sens c'est ce qu'on disait de
personnes lance un live de 20minutes tu
vois ça je comprends que c'était drôle
ou pour toi de devoir couper là surtout
il ya des gens ils ont ce bla tu vois
donc qu'ils sont satisfaits merci les
gars d'action de retour avec mais ils
vont pas être déçus
t'inquiète pas tu inquiète c'est quoi la
suite jb cash première étape ça
d'énergie ok tu reviens dans 24 heures
nous d'ici là on aura beau c on aura
beaucoup de choses à te montrer quand tu
reviendras moi je trouve des méga
passionné ça tu de ouf ça fait trop
plaisir de voir ça j'ai vraiment de voir
moi ou tout début quand je faisais ça tu
vois là on va essayer de tirer vers le
haut mais ce sera à toi ou finale de
bosser continuer à le plus important je
pense que le plus grand secret c'est
juste de se démerder pour continuer à
tout le temps et mais ce que tu fais on
a cru comprendre que tu as pause c'était
aussi parce que tu étais un peu lassé de
colloques des tons jeu favori qui ait
pas trop de jeu qui te faisais mes gars
qui fait et tu t'es pas forcé et c'est
en fait c'est trop bien vrai mais en
fait il faut toujours trouver ce
compromis entre le kif dans ce que tu
kiffes r est ce que les joueurs aussi
veulent voir mais ça c'est l'une des
seules difficultés qu'on a sur twitter
c'est de devoir trouver cet équilibre
je suis d'accord du coup bah du coup
fais ta valise mon frérot hockey marc
est maintenant alors
le sac après le sac est prêt le chat est
prêt à partir j'ai besoin des clés
montfort je fais attention mon set up en
faire très attention tu aurais pas fait
confiance
prends soin de toi pendant deux jours
neopost toi bien et quand on se retrouve
soit en forme
merci à vous l'australien adam de gens
m'ont fait rosie thiam on veut rentrer
au plus
pis ça va être un choc à janis pas c'est
c'était surréaliste absolument pas ce
qui m'arrive
[Musique]
c'est ciao ciao
on prend soin de tout promis je serai
heureux allez repose toi bien on est ce
caprice o charles chao mon vieux bijoux
les amis les zoulous des maisons merci
pour les bons alors maintenant il faut
qu'on s'organise
moi je pense que pour la partie set-up
la partie hardware expulser tout est
plus qu à l'ific manger s'est toujours
débrouillé avec tout ça du chalonnais
johnston dégâts ensuite pour les assets
twitch les alertes la bannière la photo
de profil le logo tour va tout refaire
toute la dea tweeting ce crime tout
autour faire on va apprendre cédric café
la dea de gotha domingo la mienne qui
est le gars trop chaud qui fait état cet
incroyable ce qui supposait me faire des
assiettes
il va se montrer que des merdes à 7,14
un génial et pour la déco je m'en occupe
ce mur là il faut lever ça il faut
mettre quelque chose ici ça je te laisse
faire vas-y bagot allait avancer la paix
[Musique]
bon les potes on est arrivé chez des
amis à moi des experts en matos mal
mètres bien monsieur thot
suivez moi et ça va bien organe doit
donc comme discuté au téléphone tu sais
il ya un petit streamer qui débute on
allait regarder son set up aujourd'hui
franchement il a strict minimum et nous
ce qu'on veut c'est de mettre giga bien
dis donc qu'est ce que tu nous a préparé
la avec asus rog on t'a fait deux
machines
j'aime version qu'ils puissent stream et
jouer dans les meilleures conditions
c'est celle là c'est exactement ça va ça
c'est son pc de jeu là là là mais ça va
lui changer la vie ça va être ou alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a là dedans alors là
dedans on a un amd reisen 7 5800 x à ses
processeurs donc ça c'est le processeur
avec une 3080 c'est compliqué en ce
moment les livraisons tout ça c'est très
gai là c'est vrai qu'il ya la pénurie
car grave pénurie de coeurs de rats qui
est tous les composants électroniques
down c'est quand même à trouver une
famille quatre n'a réussi à trouver une
petite famille ça c'est bien ça avec ça
on a 32 gigas de ram des classes pour le
montage vidéo montage vidéo les échanges
doit lâcher entre les disquaires voilà
l'histoire que ce soit fluide top et
derrière on a réussi à mettre un petit
ssd un terrain nvm eux histoire que les
chargements de jeu ce film m'a et les
temps de chargement apex warzone c'est
fini ça et du coup pour le pc streaming
on est un peu parti sur la même config
soif qu'on est parti sur une premier 70
kg avait pas besoin de prendre bien plus
intense et on est partis pareil sur 32
gigas de ram et un rail zone 9 par
contre ça c'est du luxe quand lui est
permis un petit nvm à l'intérieur de 512
giga pour les échanges de fichiers est
aussi un terrain histoire que les reee
corde à huawei comme ça il peut report
sur le pc stream c'est ça tout
instrument il peut 'record' en plus et
c'est de la bouche il trop excité j'ai
trop hâte de voir sa réaction
qu'est ce que tu as prévu en écran 2 8
360 r 360 r ça va être d'une fluidité
impeccable et en a pas qu'un il y en a
un deuxième au chaos à monsieur laisse
pas faire jouer sur deux écrans en même
temps nos problèmes at il dit quoi
parce qu'il y en a encore un troisième
nom le rock swift tg 2 148 181 x pour le
peut ce soir il faut que c'est pas assez
fluide alors au tour devait elle pas
aussi fluide que son pc de jeu et bien
le mec qui va se régaler qu'est-ce qui
les gâter nos mères
gardez ça les gars et les trucs sont
plus grands que moi je fais deux mètres
les gars c'est n'importe quoi et 10 mois
que les cartons et percussions plus
petit parce que on va pas seulement lui
donner deux ordinateurs on va aussi tout
me refaire il aura tout tout tout c'est
pour ça qu'on lui a trouvé avec logitech
eu un stream cam la stream cap donc ça
c'est pour lui permettre d'avoir une
meilleure qualité visuelle et la
profondeur de champ ce qui est inédit
pour une webcam pour ça c'est très bien
pour la qualité de son stream ça va être
top
on lui a pris du coup une souris
logitech pro x superlight s'il te plaît
morgan c'est la toute dernière
donc c'est là et ultra légères logitech
j'en suis possesseur j'en suis
utilisateur
elle essaie de la bombe atomique alors
est ce que tu as tapis de souris qui
recharge tout seul aussi mais qu'est ce
qui va être bien le reflet chargeur sans
fil pour la souris donc ça c'est un
tapis de souris qui recharge dassouri
automatiquement c'est sur la région soit
c'est ça
voilà c'est balèze je n'ai même pas sa
zone va falloir passer à la boutique non
mais je vais repasser la boutique trois
mois les questions à d'autres laon
clavier derrière pour le clavier un
petit j'ai 915 tkl mais qu'elle allait
mécanique et en plus on n'a pas le pavé
numérique donc quand tu déplaces la
souris tu te colle paraît suspect comme
toujours dessus et dernier le plus
important le casque et de vie d'avant
c'est vrai un logitech pro x et c'est
sans fils a ouai c'est aussi un sans fil
donc là on est vraiment sur un setup
logitech foule sans fil et une petite
dernière chose
oh c'est pas fini et non ti dernière
chose si switch deux ports usb pour les
deux pc qui permet d'avoir un seul
clavier une seule souris pour les deux
ordinateurs avec le petit presse bouton
là on peut alterner entre les deux pc
donc il pourrait gérer le pc stream et
le pc gaming en un clic il est en train
de jouer il appuie sur le bouton il veut
modifier un truc sur obs up here appui
et revient sur le donc tu es en train de
me dire que moi actuellement j'ai deux
claviers deux souris ouais et je
pourrais avoir ce truc heures exactement
les autres va la voir avant moi il faut
un début à tout ok morgan tout ça c'est
excellent demain le plan on va chez lui
on installe tous ont leur egan qui fait
33 degrés en plus et on va faire monter
la température comme chez lui face ou si
tu es prêt on sera ok on y va vas-y
adore merci morgan à demain
[Musique]
et comment tu vas ça va les gars alors
nickel mais qu'on lui a prévu des trucs
là et a toujours ton sac de randonnée
parents très important tu cesses pour
survivre les 33 degrés qu'il fait à
paris actuellement tu l'as mis sur le
top du dernier cri dont l'ami le top du
top
cédric thériault diack s'allumant alors
cédric bonjour cédric il ya un passif
entre cédric l eau claire attention
c'est parti
locklear t nouveau à 7 ils arrivent
quand je sais pas ça fait 3 à 6 mois je
les attends qui devait s'en charger ou
je ne sais pas mais je crois qu'il
s'appelle cédric alors cédric ici
présent est un monstre des assets which
c'est le boss qu'est ce que c'est des
assets switch c'est l'identité visuelle
de tachkent which may sur twitch il faut
beaucoup plus que juste une petite
bannière et une photo de profil
il faut un whiting screen avant qu'elle
ne commence il faut des émoticônes pour
tes somme il faut des badges
d'abonnement devant les pseudos des gens
dans le chat il faut les box où le
player est les bannières c'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de matière à créer
pour ça un homme en france et le plus
talentueux de tous c'est cédric ici
présents qui a fait mais à 7
tafer coiffer gotaga aussi tafer domingo
domingos et et romain donc je récapitule
zod
il est fan de marvel et des super héros
il est fan des lumières des néons des rg
baisser la pâte décor mélamine petite
led en outre son mur en guise de décor
en attendant on pourra faire un vrai
truc il est vraiment fan de lumière et
hook et il aime beaucoup je crois le
rouge et bleu du coup est ce que tu as
pu nous préparer un petit mood board un
petit truc des esquisses des intentions
kouao est globalement au rôle à ce qu'on
a fait c'est le mood board pour toute la
direction artistique
on est vraiment parti sur les
informations que vous aviez donné de
technologie
mais on est des couleurs qui match bien
ensemble qui sont le rouge et le bleu
globalement on est quand même sur des
choses qui font appel à des super héros
on avait trouvé aussi tout un côté néons
avec les câbles les reflets aussi
souvent que ça se reflète et ouais ça
fait un peu de ça c'est très très bien
donc je crois que généralement on tape
sur un logo qui est un peu de
signification et ensuite on dérive de ce
logo pour faire un peu tout le reste est
ce que doivent faire des petits schémas
de l'eau au rex laquelle bolt a tout
prévu teint si seulement il avait fait
ça pour toi grotte aussi simplement
ideas est de dung quât cedex ok donc on
a cette probable ok pour moi c'est elle
directement mais pas de débat avec
creuser allaient creuser elle est un
mode badge de super héros ou de voitures
de luxe
on a aussi qui pisse porte aussi équipe
histoire est très ému son c'est vrai
mais voilà c'est ça écusson mais ce qui
est bien parce qu'un écusson tu peux le
dérivé en badge de seube eux-mêmes
simple pour du maire
tout ça ça peut être nous ils voient les
choses en grand les zodiac auront dû
mersch
moi je suis très chaud que tu m'envoies
tout ça par mail parce que je vais le
transmettre à la personne je vais aller
voir maintenant qui s'appelle léa qu'est
notre experte déco et qui est méga show
d'elle à un atelier de fouilles elle est
très forte en travaux manuels anglais à
peine plus forte que moi en travaux
manuels mais un tout petit peu à peine
mais vraiment c'est impressionnant ce
qu'elle sait faire et j'aimerais bien
lui envoyer tout ça comme ça elle va
déjà pouvoir taper dessus et comme ça
quand j'ai vu tout à l'heure elle a
l'envié peut avancer quoi que l'idée
c'est juste qu'elle fasse un truc qui
est grave
raccord avec la dgac cédric a fait tu
vois ouais c'est à dire que les deux se
complètent bien quelques tu arrives pas
sur un live via des néons partout sur
les acef et irl je n'ai pas eu d un mur
en bois derrière lui et ces gens ce que
ça veut dire
hier elle savage erin weir light mais
qu'est ce que ça veut bien dire
tout ça veut dire dans la vraie vie vous
avez entendu j'adore créer ce genre de
sion tu nous emmerdes c'est pour ça
qu'il n'a pas fêté à cette pièce à tous
les colis l'on pouvait plus envoyez moi
ça et je vais tout de suite la voir et
croyez moi on va lui faire un truc
vraiment cool ça marche on envoie tout
ça je vous aime surtout l'un de vous
deux bisous bon c'est bien ok à nous
deux alors mais à sept sous
[Musique]
ok on est devant l'atelier déco on va
rejoindre les rangs j'ai hâte de voir ce
qu'elle a préparé pour votre netbook
[Musique]
pour propos les bons jours tranquilles
et a bien je te résume way situation
mais ce que je vois c'est tout aussi the
odd jeunes streamer passionnés de
malades genre mega a investi il a
quelques passions il a quelques coups on
a réussi un peu à lui tirer les vers du
nez avec l'ocs il est fan de marvel de
chou gens sont fondées crans et spider
man
ensuite il a des lumières chez lui
partout son micro fait de la lumière son
clavier fait de la lumière sont passés
de la lumière est kif ça tarsus que je
t'ai envoyé toute esquisse de cédric
j'ai reçu tout ça et grâce au petit logo
made envoyé ici on va aller faire un
truc cool on va lui faire son logo en
plaques' avec de la laide à l'intérieur
boum c'est derrière lui pendant qu'il se
remet ça s'allume et où c'est trop stylé
c'est bien egotrip ça j'aime bien bien
bling il lui faut la classique aux
étagères c'est évident il y en a plein
d'âme un petit meuble à côté du canapé
des étagères au mur on peut mettre toute
sa collection pour lui ramène des trucs
en plus il a plein de jeux ps vita
mettre là-dedans il a aussi des blu ray
il un coffret game of thrones tout ça
ils veulent maintenant son décor je
pense tu as promis des petites affiches
j'ai prévu de sites affichent elles sont
un peu partout la toux grasse et ça va
très bien au québec c'est sur des
références un peu classique tu vois des
trucs qui parle à tout le monde ça y va
kiffer et la couleur très important
ouais la couleur du mur la couleur du
mur de base on était parti sur du bleu
pour faire ressortir le rouche ma vie
démarre wagon bleu rouge america tout ça
est ce que toi c'est un truc que tu qui
comme on va mettre beaucoup d'affichés
doit on va un peu chargé le truc le logo
en plexiglas ont leur rouge et tout ça
tue mais je pense qu'il faut que le mur
soit un peu sobre pour que tout ce qui
est posée sur le mur ressorte tu vois ce
que je devrais je matin je lis tu
verrais plus mais un truc moins flashy
tu vois ouais un petit gris pour rester
dans le giron du score gries et savoure
ça va avec tout et ça va vraiment faire
ressortir les pets de couleurs je prends
je pensais mais je pense que c'est mieux
et le canap on garde son truc manon est
pourri son cas n'a franchement pas
manqué de dire non non on va lui mettre
un truc un peu cette étude il dort
dedans ils sont vrais liens là on fait
pas un décor on refait vraiment un peu
là partent deux autres noms mais il va
kiffer petits canapés lits super confort
le truc est douce et du velours
tu mets une petite plante ben oui il
quitte tout on aime bien le mélange
lumière plante ça vous fait plaisir ça
tu de ouf
génial bats toi de jouer bah je suis
déjà en installe tous demain tu auras le
temps devenait ouais tu es le boss trop
bien et ben écoute travail bien moi je
vais en terrasse bon tu en penses quoi
tout ça grosse journée mais c'est pas
nous qui faisons une blague cette fois
ceux des vrais travaux c'est sûr c'est
pas autres ils se cachent pas là bas
bien emballant devient on l'appelle le
beau bilan stress et toulon l'a fait
partir et au conseil dresse finissez pas
vu qu'on voit des gens forts et bong
surtout que ça fait une journée que le
mec qui on a 100 à porte mais sourd il
nous a donné des classes et facilement
il a une bonne confiance en eux après tu
es le premier tu veux rebondir excuse a
prêté le premier streamer de la galaxie
aussi on est prêt vas-y toi et toi ça va
trop où est ce que tu es là ma mère là
on avait quelques soucis à l'appart de
gaza fait mal car j'arrête la blague
jani lane fardeau excuse moi tu fais
suivre mais il est temps de changer son
matériel parce que regarde sa caméra
frise bon juste pour te tenir au courant
tout je lis créhin on a vu des gens on a
prévu des choses c'est juste pour te
prévenir ce col que tout avance bien
donc repose toi bien profite bien parce
qu'après c'est charbon honnêtement je
suis prêt et quand je dis tiens on n'est
toujours pas les grâce à la aucun sens
ça n'a aucun sens quatre ans ont passé
mais moi j'ai quand même une question
c'est aturine est une nouvelle fois
depuis toutefois à ça a débloqué début
ça va c'est comme ça qu'on mesure le
stress de ses serres en urines que je
vous fais confiance de toute façon de ce
côté là t'as fait quoi aujourd'hui du
coup je vais être honnête avec toi j'ai
eu l'impression de revivre depuis des
longues années en fait par un problème
en fait le bonheur et je te jure ça fait
des années j'ai pas vécu ça en fait je
suis allée ou dans un centre commercial
je me suis pas là des sens très jeune tu
fais un petit resto tout seul on vient
ça le reste au sol seraient j'avais
l'inter le restaurateur ce soit en
danger je t'ai issia lorsque tu regardes
et le foot avec les copains est vraiment
j'ai l'impression d'être heureux pour la
première fois depuis de longues années
mais toi vraiment bien et façon tu veux
tu verras ça vaut le coup et demain je
pense que tu vas est trop content je
pense qu'on a bien bossé avec l'ocs en
tout cas nous on est méga fier et j'ai
trop hâte que tu vois ce qu'on prépare
et que du bonheur j'en profite à 100% et
c'est pas que deux jours l'objectif pour
toi c'est de trouver leur équilibre
justement entre les futurs stream 2
professional et avis perso et qu'il soit
trop heureux de malades et comme je t'ai
dis ça fait des années c'est pas aussi
un plaisir en fait n'est pas revenu
dessus mais ton live là quand tu as mis
à rude épreuve a assuré un t'as vraiment
été excellent c'est pas facile hein tu
as live tu savais qu'on était là il y
avait aussi plein de gens autour de toi
dans la pièce qui te regarder vraiment
je te le dis tapas et il a explosé le
test merci à vous les gars vraiment
génie vous attends attends ça se trouve
tu vas tout à y redire face à attend de
voir ce qui se passe à temps parce qu'on
va saccager ton appartement puis j'ai
pas la portée sur le bon point donc
attendre l'attaquant vendre
l'appartement voilà voilà continue de te
reposer profite bien et on se voit
demain on t'embrasse mon vieux prends
soin de toi prends soin de ton mec on
est trop bien ton mais on a une chance
de ouf
il est excellent genre du maxi attendait
pas il se prend un bulldozer dans la
gueule et là il est en train d'accepter
tu vois demain 7 jours où ça y est on va
chez lui on refait tout ouais et demain
soir le reveal
c'est vrai mon vieux je suis prêt on y
va on va se reposer déjà les sports
séance de sport allez allez olla
seybatou méthode pour sa nounou si on
pense à nous on a bien bossé on est
fiers
bon mesdames et messieurs on est sur le
point d'arriver chez hot air un camion
on est chargé afin de conduire j'embraye
très très fort
ok mais où va bien mesdames et messieurs
c'est un professionnel cette vidéo il
fait par des professionnels
cartaut là c'est pas mal j'y vais j'y
vais j'y vais on est bon non c'est bon
[Musique]
messieurs dames
jour 2 c'est aujourd'hui que tout se
passe c'est le jour j
personne n'est prêt mais personne n'est
prêt non mais non pourquoi on est prêt
parce qu'on a ramené dans ce camion tout
ce qu'il faut pour faire le setup deux
hommes de décors deux autres regardez
venait vient montrer contenu du camion
parce que c'est quand même la course et
c'est démentiel
les gars je peux vous dire qu'il ya
énormément de matos dans ce camion juste
derrière cette porte
c'est le rêve de tout gars qui jouent
aux jeux vidéo qu'il ya tout ce qu'il
faut là badiou aux salaires mais que
c'est un truc de ouf via les écrans
micro de la petite déco pop culture qui
kiffe les pc qui sont là y'a tout ya
tout et de l'autre côté où il mourir il
manque
rires c'est s'ils vendent des choses il
manque évidemment non la déco rien comme
il est beau le kanak mais qui longe les
classes assez digne des zodiacs ça c'est
un canapé sac à l'appel zodiac regard
ils amènent des petites bougies pour une
en bourse très drôles sont je suis
très content qu'ils aient un peu de
plantes aussi avec l'esprit néons et
tout ça va être trop bien mec ça tue
mais on il arrive dans huit heures
on doit tout installer maintenant tu es
prêt on ne fait pas du sport pour tous
les deux c'est aujourd'hui que doit
servir tu es obligé de dire que tu fais
du sport c'est pour arrête tu m'a exposé
gérard gens d'être valérie damidot bah
ouais ouais
quoi je ne sais pas ce qui je suis qui
on a une équipe qui est là avec nous et
qui va nous aider à tous d installer ce
qu'il a et réinstaller tout ça à la
place et aussi à un seuil toute la
partie hardware c'est relou un setup obs
les nouveaux à 7 et c'est un truc est
assez chiant quand même pour ça y'a du
monde qu'elle a avec nous on va à
briefer les équipes et on y va c'est
parti ah oui les amis on y est le jour j
c'est le jour où zod va être très ému et
très heureux
on l'a vu d'ailleurs hier en visio il
est comme un au filet genre trop et
c'est un petit resto tout seul il est
trop content et il sait même pas quand
vous avez vous les boss de différents
milieux aujourd'hui on a besoin de vous
les gars arnaud les gros bras la force
tranquille du groupe et aussi la force
musculaire du groupe
tu vas te charger de descendre tous les
items quand on veut plus et de monter
tout ce qu'on a besoin de monter qui se
trouvent dans ce camion les abords de la
déco savais tu as toi d'installer le nez
au mur les étagères les affiches le
canap tout ça morgane cédric les petits
tics du groupe les petits boss du
hardware des acef vous devez paramétrer
tout son set up stream et c'est un peut
presque plus important j'ai envie de
dire il faut que ça marche du tonnerre
je veux aucun bug aucun problème
technique moindre bug vous allez à faire
- il rigole pas avec les bois je déconne
pas avec les boucheries qui rigole pas
de bug over live fluide avec aucun
problème je veux que 15 ordres ils
arrivent ils puissent directement
l'ancien live en appuyant sur un bouton
je mets un peu trop de pression un peu
trop de pression et vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'on a que 8 heures alors on y
parlait de voile elle était allée go
allez on y va mon vieux allez c'est
parti et nous c'est pas toi qui porte
les cartons jaunes tu fais du sport mais
là toute la coulent douce
si vous allez c'est parti je prédis que
des trucs louches way
zone mon frérot tu vas vraiment une
berne
[Musique]
hop là le tapis la petite plante des
familles jamais vu autant de propre
rodman et toutes les femmes même ancien
fan moi aussi je suis plein boom et on
s'en fout là il va sacrément envie de se
placer
c'est un petit fils ou les pc les futurs
bébés 2 à 2 qui l'aimera plus que tout
au monde
en tout cas certainement bien plus que
celui ci c'est un petit filou cet
ascenseur au la ricamarie garden café
est illégal
et oui mon gars tu es je vais vous dire
une chose c'est que zod à l'issue de
cette vidéo aura un meilleur cannes avec
moi et ça ça me fait un peu mal et il
aura derrière ces sept que pas les miens
à 7,1 maire pc 1 mais en micro ce qu'on
n'a pas fait pour nous le concept c'est
ça pourquoi tu l'as pas fait pour moi là
je suis content tu vois que tu fasses
beaucoup de sport là dans sa salle de
sport avec ta propre ton gagner' là je
suis heureux voici celles ci servent là
[Musique]
excusez moi les cameramans mais là on
est en train de préparer l'entrée zodiac
cette attention à vous regarder qui
ramène le gros du truc qui se tapent le
groupe du truc c'est toujours pareil je
peux vous dire que déménager à cette
période de l'année c'est une sacrée idée
de merde
c'est un peu trop là sur la plante c'est
ok j'avoue la planta laplaud mais il ya
tellement de trucs j'ai tellement hâte
de monter tout ça
ceci dit le mur gris a été peint avant
qu'on arrive tout à l'heure par l'équipe
et je trouve ça excellent c'est mieux
mais je pense que c'était le bon choix
tu vois c'est sobre et tous les trucs on
va rajouter font kiffer par dessus ça va
être vraiment bien imaginer au delà il
est probablement chez sa mère sous la
véranda
il s'est fait un petit martin et olives
il est là genre et il sait quand ils
arrivent ils c'est ça tu je suis trop
content pour lui j'étais g3 qui voit et
surtout j'espère ça lui plaît j'espère
aussi aller au boulot des ballons tout
[Musique]
comment
bien spider man dont on va donner du
spider man premier qu'on dit qu on est
vraiment des zodiac tout pour le tout
pour le zodiac pour le z
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre 1 degré que les hommes sirotent
bientôt mojito j'espère salon d'hiver
allez c'est bon tu est comme ça et ça
aussi recevoir des objets c'est les
monter soi même c'est ce plaisir là ils
attendent solide 11h30 on est mort n'est
ce pas vivre en attendant par michel t
on assez attendu attendant basse au
cours du repas comme si vous appelez
commenté premier jour où wall ag ni
[Musique]
voilà sa première sens
morgan
alors voilà on est avec toi tu en es
août a bientôt fini
ouais en fait du tanit chèques sont là
deux auteurs d'actes langage de
techniciens c'est bientôt fini me
regarde bientôt la forme et à certains
problèmes regarde le set up il est
magnifique 0 ça attendez attendez
attendez il reste une dernière touch
roll alors acheté grâce à chaque attends
attends mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
à peine il parle de son tapis yoko oui
merci vaut le hashtag had mais c'est la
menace tapie
il est vraiment sympa ton tapis sache
que géniaux pied de mon lit comme ça dès
que je me lève le matin dans un squeeze
[Musique]
problème majeur on a mal paramétrée
l'appareil il a surchauffé totalement
puisqu'il fallait changer des trucs dans
les options pour pas qui surchauffe
bref vous en trouvez qu'un appareil en
surchauffe parce que là il faut attendre
vraiment longtemps avant qu'ils puissent
se rallumer si ça marche pro tools dans
le frigo entre eux un sandwich et des
compotes mon frérot super efficace on
continue à régler des problèmes imprévus
je suis en train avec les plaintes pour
la 9e fois revu sur l'ordinateur
n'hésitez pas est ce que tu peux
expliquer le pourquoi on est là il est
22h mesdames et messieurs est ce que tu
peux avoir expliqué pourquoi on est là
mais assieds toi mec
bon vous voyez ce mur derrière moi on ya
fait des trous ça se passait bien de ce
côté là et d'un coup trois impossible à
faire il ya une plaque en métal dans le
mur tout ce qu'on voulait accrocher on
pouvait pas du coup on a tenté de
rafistoler le logo éliminé deux objets
sacrés des zodiaques golic des zodiaques
mec c'est une étape extrêmement
importante soit elle est très important
comme on peut le voir on avait quelques
soucis
allez hockey en boîte dedans tu le vois
pas je le vois ont des bons temps si tu
accroches mal c'est fini on a one shot
là c'est bon salaire par contre jusqu'à
trois basiques roi demain 2 3 c'est
tourner dans les prochaines minutes sur
pas la vidéo ça s'est décroché on a
failli perdre le logo non mais regarde
regarde c'est pas notre fusil c'est la
colle c'est pas nous squeeze j'ai passé
l'âge
finalement grâce au travail acharné de
l'équipe qui était là et qui est plutôt
là d'ailleurs je crois que tout le monde
est complètement épuisé puisqu'il fait
38 degrés là dans l'appart
on a complètement changé la dispo et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est encore
mieux que ce qu'on avait prévu
je suis ravie en fait on a inversé
l'étagère avec le canapé job et du coup
on a pu poser le logo sur l'étagère
évidemment on a pu mettre du coup un
petit cadre ici histoire de combler un
peu le truc ça faisait et il nous reste
un dernier truc à gérer c'est le set up
il régente de trois réglages pour tout
soit bien fluide et qui les héros bugs
et a pris enfin on peut l'appeler bois
0 0
tu as bien travaillé bravo tu as très
bien travailler aux champs je suis
exterminés il est 22h30
il devait arriver à calais rappelle moi
il devait arriver à une entente hors
cour oui les gars c'était intense on a
vraiment eu face à beaucoup de problèmes
que vous avez pu voir mais franchement
je suis méga content du résultat
tout est plié le set-up le décor les
assets tout est paramétré lesquels tout
est bon c'est le moment que zod attend
impatiemment qu'il a quitté sète alès
dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qui se fit perdre mon temps et mon
problème j'ai dû retrouver ce père est
ce qu'ils ont fait un dégât des eaux
ce ton qui nous écoutent les eaux or on
l'appelle ces moments il nous rappelle
quand il est en bas on descend lui bande
les yeux neufs et ont fait monter ici on
y découvre labarthe masi mais je
l'appelle l'adorent bah oui bon ok je
pense qu'ils attendent qu'elle fait
depuis 18h30 salle izzo ça va mon vieux
attend quoi
c'est comme ça je suis trouvée c'était
sportif zod
mais je crois que on est prêt à ce que
tu reviennes rappelle moi quand tu es en
bas de l'immeuble et redescendre
chercher ok je suis ok bon redescends
direct chercher hockey a tout de suite
mon vieux disait malade il sait pas que
en fait on a fait un double des clés
qu'on va changer la serrure et c'est un
studio and one avec lola allons chercher
a donc cherché
c'est parti voilà il est là ça va
essayer de rouler juste avant ça va mais
là vraiment président je vous dis je
vous ai dit les gars bons mecs
on s'est vraiment donné et l'équipe
encore plus que nous mais crois moi le
résultat en vaut la peine
en fait on a hésité même à atteindre la
clôture on s'est dit franchement bien
d'enfin studio pour vous mais j'ai pensé
j'ai pensé que j'allais perdre mon
appart
tu m'as lagrave apaisé et je suis trop
content tu savais que ce n'était pas le
cas gardien quatre heures quand je suis
arrivé ici vraiment j'ai juste ruines
c'est qu'ils montent découvrir un peu
comment elle a fait pour ça kelowna sur
ses yeux c'est bon c'est bon tu vois
rien de dangereux
ici un du monde il faut le tenir parce
que ça tombe bien comme ça rien tu es
bien très bien
tu peux aller tout droit des biens dans
la moi j'aime bien le fait qu'on lui
mettre le masque dès maintenant il
connaît rien on connaissait la gauche là
bas là tu vas gauche inquiète la toiture
au marché il ya vraiment le troll par
mois n'ont jamais acheté trois clics et
j'appuie son ascenseur sont à sentir qui
est d'une rare violence
les violons les atlas et tout ça c'est
vrai l'impression qu'on va se marier
vraiment je sais pas là bas il ya des
ados témoigne à nos bagues
ok ok là on arrive on arrive devant ton
appart
là on va rentrer dans une abarth les
mains devant la belle voix rapporte que
tu voies de fait sur ta gauche se dit
inquiète paillard et au niveau des pieds
ok je te guide on est bien et là tu
t'arrêtes et tu attends hockey z
on est face à ton appartement
actuellement tu ne peux pas le voir
non tu es pressé
foot tu as tu oui énormément moi j'ai
hâte aussi ça y est là mon frérot on a
tout donné on espère que ça plaira tu
retires ton masque quand tu veux quand
je veux je retire mon insu fait sourire
tous risques
[Musique]
quoi bienvenue dans ton nouveau site web
avant l'épée c'est enfin le jour
j'ai un petit os si j'y crois bon c'est
chez moi vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y
tranquillement sa voix ou juste ici tout
nouveau clic clac
qu'est ce que c'est que ça matière
velours bleu métallique il suffit de
tirer pour qu'ils passent en mode qui
claque je vais pas le faire j'ai pas
envie de casser juste ici tu le sais pas
encore mais ça c'est ton nouveau logo
montferrand mon frère c'est le logo deux
hommes
le logo des zodiac on savait que les
fans de marvel en a mis plein de trucs
marvel un peu partout talca ce batman
d'iron man marteau de thor le guen
thanos on a vu tel mais bien spider man
c'est au fond d'écran de l'ami on a un
tapis formidable quand même remarquer
d'entrée de jeu je suis ravi qu'il met
en avant
ça me touche au four est ce que cette
toute jeune mais je continue à penser
que la tumeur au cerveau des émotions va
présenter tout juste ici bouclier de
captain america encore une étagère avec
du fg c'est vrai il était ok ok c'est
cool c'est le roi qui savent enseignera
filet et là mon vieux
là c'est simple tu as mieux que moi et
locke je te jure c'est vrai maintenant
c'est pay pwyp malware let's go home
hardware du à le pc asus rog chaise un
statut à mon vieux installe toi mais on
a vu que tu voulais prendre ton dos
c'est la faisait là s'émeut 1 m 80 c'est
ça on sait tout sur tout à zéro elle est
déjà réglé pour 1 mètre 80 bah oui on
s'était bien ici
hop là les pieds entre les deux pc à
gauche et le pc gaming rock streaming
écoute mon vieux c'est très simple en
matos ans tami le best tu connais
matériel logitech avec la super l'adq
est sorti a pas si longtemps que ça
cette souris là je suis père prince je
suis perdue on fait donc ses premières
servir d'un mur avant qu'on découvre tsl
de chercher des as est évidemment on a
fait faire refaire toute la direction
artistique par un professionnel café la
mienne celle de gotha et qui bosse très
souvent pour plein de streamer qui leur
fait leurs assets tu vas voir une
direction artistique très soignée la
carte sont préférés des streamer
restitue gère ton micro et si tu gères
le retour de ton pc jeux ici tu gères le
retour de ton pc stream le micro tu le
connais le blues parc éditions noir je
savais même pas qu'il existe évidemment
aux caméras un tamis la stream gamme de
logitech est très très bien et on a
aussi mis un côté un sony à 6000 avec un
objectif qui te fera un gros coup
derrière toi et comme il ya des petits
clyde est à toi petit ami un peu des rg
benetton lumière sa trame maxi beau
gosse le stream dès que tu connais ton
avait déjà un bien c'est top des siennes
on voulait découvrir dans un instant
mais je n'ai pas terminé
qu'est ce que c'est que ce casque ce ne
serait pas le logitech pro etc
mais si c'est un casque c'est un très
bon casque gaming maintenant un truc
très important pour un streamer tulle
ccca cet étang avait des biens que tu as
fais toi même chose avec son briquet etc
on les a fait refaire par un pro de pros
de pro voici ton écran d'intro de live
ça ses contacts en train de te prépares
était en train de lancer ton live tu
mets ça whiting sprint scène cinq
minutes 10 minutes et jean izard
émission ait eu ma petite musique
derrière boum ça envoie tu vois mais
c'est moi en fait j'ai l'impression de
devoir dans cette plaine vrai
c'était moi mais quand enfin non
vraiment c'est vous dire que je suis
très difficile à quelqu'un on attend
numéro de passeport on a tout ce qu'il
faut au tac at on sait tous ce téléphone
est super bien on a fait les choses bien
on s'est renseigné sur toi estimé wen
j'adore j'adore c'est incroyable j'adore
c'est quoi j'ai même pas sa samba sall
je vais donner l'anecdote tu vas adorer
cédric devait faire les assets de l'eau
claire et jamais elle est au bout pour x
raison puisque lui c'est un individu
instable donc à tout à sète on est
d'accord il ya pas qu un écran de début
non contre j'en ai encore un peu de
rouge tentant ensuite on a un écran de
pause si jamais tu veux faire une petite
pause genre halle aux toiles et la
situation en train de se stabiliser
très bien et juste après tu as
évidemment ton écran de faim les néons
peu à peu les états qui s'éteignent
c'est fou foule calme quand tu veux
discuter avec ton chat et on sait que tu
adores discuter avec ton chat parce que
certains gestion regarde donc ça c'est
quand tu parles aux jo quand on est
coach du sco d'angers cadres ont donc
besoin de toi tu comptes stream et sur
quels jeux par exemple prochainement
alors apex énormément chivalry chivalry
oiseaux il ya deux pièces états unis ben
justement chivalry chivalry 2 tu vas
jouer à timothée 2 c'est génial on est
mort avant que j'ai fais un set je dois
de faire une petite confession
bienveillant il ya une plaque en métal
dans tout au mur on peut pas percé
d'accord donc c'est ça pendant la
solution c'est de mettre du 3ème
derrière c'est des trucs des scotchs des
baux pro etc
sauf que comme on s'est éternisé
pourrait trouver de solution tous les
magasins fermés on n'a pas pu aller en
acheter
je regarderai dans la vidéo tous les
problèmes qu'on a eus et c'est pour ça
que ça se termine tard il est navré zone
des gars du jour je suis vraiment sans
mot fringer pas tu nous en veut c'est
pour ça que je serai le mur c'est
chouette est absolument faux c'est
absolument faux rien ah c'est toi c'est
ça aussi il a dit qu'on n'allait pas le
jeter par la fenêtre
non non jamais prendre un peu au quai tu
peux parler du coup le temps je peux non
on n'a pas qu'il y en a pas fini alors
qu'elle entame évidemment le nom du
garde des sceaux
le nombre de sobres le nombre de faux
l'eau le nom du dernier followers sans
compter qu'on a aussi mis les alertes
donc dès qu'il ya un mec qui s'habille à
une nouvelle alerte une petite animation
etc tu demanderas tu es seul personnel a
tourné là et j'ai vraiment l'innocent
genre à chaque fois que c'est autre
chose et je m'en fous des sobre mais
merci à trappes 1,78 demander pourquoi
devrait on a vraiment un master i pour
résister ou fait un master croire à mon
frérot tu es tellement fort merci mon
frérot ça me fait plaisir
ensuite il reste deux scènes la cam jeu
évidemment donc quand tu joues comme jeu
tranquillement tu feras gafsa stream
l'intégralité de ton écran et ensuite tu
as la scène qu'elle vit mieux la scène
gaming ou là c'est vraiment toi en petit
et ton jeu en grand donc là en fait tout
ce qu'il reste à faire concrètement met
ses deux lancers constitue en ce sens
rim et tu fais ce que tu aimes je vous
proposais à ce que les gars dix mois on
s'assoit en bois de l'eau ce qui fait
chaud et on discute zod
alors dis nous tout est ce que tu aimes
bien le décor vous allez faire un taf de
ouf
le logo frère du marvel partout où tu
sais en fait c'est tout c'est moi en
fait ce cas c'est fou c'est que j'ai des
goûts particuliers donc ce que je fais
je sais que je vais aimer en fait et je
n'aime pas trop qu'on fasse pour moi
parce que voilà je suis jamais d'accord
jeu j'aime bien que ce soit moi qui
fasse ça veut rien dire non si je me
reconnais vachement dans ce que tu dis
on n'est jamais mieux servi que par
soi-même exactement fait je réalise
toujours pas là pour moi c'est on est en
train de tourner je vais rentrer chez
moi après vous rendez vous compte vous
avez changé la vie de quelqu'un voilà j
pal et vous avez changé la vie de
quelqu'un va trouver un mec moi je
trouve honteux c'est notre objectif
c'était l'objectif parce que faire tout
ça en réalité ces genres très chaud pour
quelqu'un qui a envie pas encore quelle
idée de jeu bien sûr de chaque euro qui
l'investît doit être genre optimisée à
300% c'est super dur à gérer comme
situation elles sont pas forcément
compte mais nous on l'a vécu aussi ce
truc là et des tas de gens de vivre
m'ont parlé c'est vraiment un truc est
très dur âge elle l'a en fait a vraiment
tout pour t'éclater de ouf et c'est cool
et ça qu'on voulait l'offrir et la
mission est accomplie j'ai l'impression
que j'ai l'impression que c'est mission
gérer l'impression que ces messieurs là
en fait je vais quand tu dis m'éclater
en fête et ses buts pour moi le but de
twitch je vais disputer des heurts avec
les gens pour raconter cette histoire là
aussi qu'est kck ses fabuleuses devait
raconter comment ta dégager de chetouane
d'un problème sur mon pc quand je
lançais un jeu parfois ça grise y est
j'ai toujours d'éteindre le rester il
rallume et l'as mussig au psg de
machines baker en fait je refuse ce
problème
et puis avec ma table de mixage virtuel
d'une vraie table de mixage et sikhs en
fait moi j'avais des questions pour toi
dis moi on a vu que tu stream et plus
pendant un mois avant qu'on arrive et
c'est genre pas du tout grave tu vois
c'est des trucs arrive c'est quoi les
vraies raisons est ce que c'est ce que
tu nous
dix se trouvent des jetés témoins dans
vous en parler c'est un peu je vais pas
casser l'ambiance par raconte ce n'est
pas grave en fait ça me fait du bien tu
dois parler du coup j'ai perdu mon papa
il ya quatre ans en fait j'y associe
trop cette période mais où j'ai mon
anniversaire juillet août à la maladie
de mon père et au décès de mon père qui
est mort en juillet c'est chaque année
depuis le décès mon père toute l'année
ça se passe bien et à partir de cette
période la grosse remise en question sur
ma vie sur ce que j'ai accompli sur ce
que je vais devenir sur ma mère qui
s'inquiète beaucoup pour moi et puis nos
premières c'est difficile aussi parce
qu'elle traverse la même chose et là bas
voilà c'est une période où je me
renferme énormément et grâce tahitienne
entre autres c'est vrai que j'ai appris
aussi à sortir en parler pratique fait
pendant pendant quasiment trois ans de
trois ans parlez à personne de ça donc
c'est une période qui très difficile
mais faut pas se laisser abattre faut
pas que ça serve d'excusé non plus pour
rien faire lundi enfin lundi qu arriver
là je comptais me met un coup de collier
me dire non faut pas se laisser aller je
peux pas passer toute ma vie à fuir
cette période là en fait et je comptais
me met à fond et là c'est même pas un
argument de plus ces genres
c'est donc un tremplin si si c'est une
fusée vous m'avez donné pour décoller en
fait je regarde pas d' excuses
pendant 4 ans 5 6 ans je me suis dit je
suis quelqu'un qui n'a pas de change pas
du tout chance dans la vie je suis un
poissard douves en face de moi j'ai du
mal à réaliser parce que ba machine
twitté ma bulle et ça me permet pas de
d'être mois à fond quand ça va pas je
n'aurais pas pu rêver mieux je n'aurais
pas pu rêver mieux et c'est fantastique
ben franchement on est tombé sur une
bonne période du coup pour venir te voir
de la chance sur ça et je trouves tu
dégage vraiment un super truc mon vieux
genre tu es trop passionné de malade et
doit pas non plus si dur avec toi mc on
a
tout le droit d'être genre mal c'est
comme ça on pourrait toujours être au
top est trop bien
tu as l'air vachement culpabiliser sur
ça il faut pas en fait pas grave du tout
tu vois j'ai une question quel méga
perçoit une deuxième rêve droit mais
j'aime bien savoir plus dimanche c'était
quoi ton accident j'étais en soirée à
rouen avec avec des amis jai vue pas
tant que ça fait ainsi un peu mais
postale va gérer le jai vue pas tant que
ça je sais pas pourquoi l'idée de me
prend d'aller observer la vue d'un peu
plus haut aux jambes la rambarde
je grimpe sur le toit pour voir la vue
il y avait de la mousse sur le toit je
glisse et je fais une chute de sept
mètres je crois 6 ou 7 mètres et je me
suis complètement fracassé sur le fémur
la hanche heures rue dictats patience
mais regarde ça tu as eu de la chance je
m'en sors sans séquelles chez le
plongeoir 5 m à la piscine me terrorise
lieu donc ses jo mamba et c'est là que
j'ai réalisé qu'en fait où est la vie
est trop courte pour pas pour pas faire
ce que tu aimes en fait moi le gaming ça
a toujours été une passion
donc je me lance en fait et ce qu'on
peut faire venir ici anne les gars quand
même parce que c'est quand même grâce à
elle qu'on est là en vrai de vrai
initiales as tu des bars et une salle
j'ai une question
oui il était comme ans au delà très mal
il n'a pas dîné il était très stressé on
a empêché de manger à yahia il a perdu
la masse musculaire
c'est grâce à toi c'est ta vidéo c'est
toi la complice c'est toi qui a assuré
ce truc là c'est complètement grâce à
toi moi je trouve très bien entourée et
aimée gars passionné
tu dis t'as pas de chance c'est faute à
des coûts de patience et des coups de
chance comme tout le monde dans la vie
mais est un truc que tu avec d'autres
n'ont pas aujourd'hui c'est la chance de
pouvoir d'éclater la gros tu vas pouvoir
t'éclater d'ouf complètement et
d'ailleurs à ce sujet
oula ce qu'ils croient que c'est terminé
en fait non s'ils croient que c'est
terminé c'est déjà pas mal et que
j'adore c'est sans arrêt sans arrêt il
va pas manger tu vois je suis un zodiac
mais j'aimerais un peu ramené plus de
zodiac sur la chaîne devait faire dos
coors
cette vidéo sera mardi au 8 août
prochain live sera jeudi à 20h30
ses succès le jeudi je crois que vous
stream et jeudis de temps en temps vous
stream et jeudi mais sont tout à fait
jeudi nous les zodiac et tous les
audiences naissance a fait cette vidéo
seront sur twitch à 20h30 sur ton live
et c'est là qu'on va y découvrir ton
tout premier live dans ce nouveau décor
avec ces nouveaux à 7
avec ce nouveau matos et avec cette
nouvelle envie de découvre avec twitch
il va y avoir du monde
d'autant plus qu'on sera en live tous
les deux et qu'on réagira at on live at
war aussi beaucoup de pression pour un
seul homme
tous ces gars là vidéo ou envie de te
voir en action là bien sûr envie de voir
ce que ça donne zone avec les instits le
matos le décor sa joie de vivre ils ont
envie de te voir live et ce sera jeudi à
20h30
évidemment on va pas trop regarder
quatre heures ou autre regard d une
heure une heure et demie et après on va
jouer ensemble évidemment falala vont
parler légal ok je pense on jouera
warzone sommes pas mal
oh oui ça me voir la très en forme il
était alors
nature là il est 23h 30 50 ou non va
devoir y aller évidemment et on a hâte
d'une chose c'est de voir en live dans
trois jours et de tecla témoins
j'ai hâte jusqu'à le premier en somme je
passerai vip peut-être moi je passerai
modo semaine non j'étais bien commandant
social commandant sodiac ça va être que
tu kiffes en fait que ça fait que du que
dutil a pas ce que tu faisais déjà parlé
avec la passion mais absolue un 4 argent
j ai fait d'avoir bien sûr il ya rien
qui va changer mon vieux ont ce magasin
dehors sinon bah voyons et a grillé la
chaleur ouais ouais bah les honneurs à
les adore c'est du bien on était là ce
matin on avait trop trop peur que tu ne
vois pas pourquoi
ah ouais on était là genre moi j'étais
paniqué les amis s'étaient clé vous êtes
vraiment aller au bout on peut faire
comme les et les télés shopi et là oh
oui bah si tu veux juste avec caméra qu
à la base et c'est ma clé c'est chez moi
mon nouveau c'est top
merci merci les gars vraiment merci nous
sommes maintenant ça toi de jouer
je suis trop content qu'on soit vu je
trouve autant d'amour pour toi j'ai
trois dates jeudi et les gens aussi
ouais ils seront là sur twitter point tv
slash fr enders score z c'est beau très
rendez-vous les futurs josiane vous a
tant donné mes amis j'ai envie de vous
faire un câlin bravo pour cette belle
aventure je trouve s'est trouvée et
bravo aussi à tous qui si elle est là
elle est discrète elle est dans un coin
n'est plus de chaleur mais c'est grâce à
toi tout ça tu as été une complice
extraordinaire je vais te spoiler loc
il était convaincu que zod était au
courant vraiment il était chez moi
pendant deux heures et tourner en rond
et lukas pas possible si on arrivait que
ces rochers c'est qu'il est au courant
ils étaient ils étaient des terres mais
j'étais au courant de rien
mais ça tu vois ses initiales qui a
tellement bien bossé franchement c'est
vraiment quelqu'un il faut garder ma
mais bien sûr mais je lui fais tellement
confiance j'ai fait tellement confiance
que je vais faire et pourtant je sais
pas quand mais je te fais confiance
facilement
donc voila mais c'est une surprise
totalement réussi les amis je vais vous
avoir un truc que je m'évanouis de
fatigue et bien c'est peut être l'heure
de couper cette vidéo de monsieur mort
mais j'ai pas envie d'y mettre fin en
même temps c'est pas une fin c'est un
début zod way à jeudi 20h30 way is yan
tu seras pas loin gérard la repose toi
bien dors bien mais merci à ces bons
syndication et j'ai l'impression de
revenir de partir de colonies de
vacances à mais vraiment juger ça me
fait mal au coeur c'est vrai que sais je
sais pas quand mon médecin jeu j'ai pas
envie
[Musique]